ми маємо об'єднатись не навколо прізвищ
ми маємо об'єднатись не навколо структур
зараз а навколо єдиного збройних сил
України і вибачте будь ласка залишати в
бюджеті воюючої країни мільярди на
марафон мільярди на канал ради який
перетворився на найогидніше
пропагандистське дійство на репресівні
органи на прокуратуру Це просто ганьба
тут дуже багато звучить зараз знаєте
прикладів до Ізраїля так а покажіть мені
А де в Ізраїлі марафон де в Ізраїлі
єдиний марафон і хтось на олігарх чні
канали там з бюджету виділяє кошти
можливо давайте виправляйте ваші помилки
щоб вам не соромно було солдатам і
офіцерам дивитися в очі